[Music]
if you want to be good do what they say
you should but if you want to be great
you
innovate Whitney wolf heard CEO and
founder of bumble the youngest woman to
take a company
public we need to rewrite the rules
let's do
it I will speak vulnerably about the
difficulties I'm having somewhere to see
a leader be vulnerable it makes people
feel
[Music]
connected
contrary to popular belief Bumble
started with a pretty modest budget we
had to be really thoughtful and really
really creative I'm going to show you
how to do that
too don't hold yourself back by
society's perception of who you
are why aren't we being the masters of
our own
destiny I'm Whitney wolf herd and this
is Master
Class
[Music]